bella phare n'y a scruté par les
autorités italiennes
cette communauté sikh de 30000 habitants
vit dans la région de sabaudia à 100 km
au sud de rome
parmi eux 80 personnes ont été déclarées
positives au cofidis et au début nous
étions très inquiets
puis ils ont fait tous ces tests nous
avons appris qu'il y avait quelques cas
positifs et ils ont mené ces personnes
en quarantaine en dehors de la zone
tout le monde reste donc à la maison
quelques personnes sont allées au
travail avec un certificat car elle
était négative
désormais nous sommes plus tranquilles
nous attendons des informations des
responsables de la santé si pour le
moment les séquençages sont toujours en
cours et que la présence d'un variant
n'est pas confirmée la région a tout de
même été placé en zone rouge bar
restaurant et de nombreuses autres
installations de loisirs ferme donc au
public les points d'entrée sont
surveillés et les habitants doivent
réduire leurs déplacements au strict
minimum
comme pour se rendre au travail ou faire
leurs courses
par précaution même si la situation
n'est pas critique j'ai pris l'avis du
service sanitaire et j'ai décidé de
suspendre l'enseignement en présentiel
et de le faire en ligne pendant une
semaine la saison des plages a également
été retardée d'une semaine pour avoir
une idée plus claire de la situation et
garantir la sécurité et la santé de tous
car c'est notre objectif
à ce jour il n'y a que deux cas officiel
du variant indien en italie il s'agit
d'un père et de son fils habitants au
nord de venise qui venait de rentrer et
d'inde
face à la flambée de contagion au co
vite 19 qui frappent l'inde
rome a interdit dimanche 25 mars
l'entrée sur son territoire de personnes
en provenance de ces pays mais n'a pas
suspendu les vols notamment pour
permettre aux ressortissants italiens de
regagner la péninsule